BuzzFeed says most of most of cash and
cash equivalents held at svb
buses from Yahoo finance BuzzFeed Inc
Reuters actually said on Monday that
most of its cash and equivalents were
held at Silicon Valley Bank which was
shut down
startup Focus under svb last week failed
shares and BuzzFeed were down 8.6 at
1.17 in extended trading Monday wow
that's really bad Silver Linings it's
like well I mean like it's down eight
percent which is really bad but they're
only at a dollar Seventeen per share
anyway which is just really bad the
company which has been grappling with a
tough advertising Market amid concerns
over a slowing economy also reported a
27 decline in ad Revenue to 50 million
dollars in the quarter ending December
31st it expects first quarter overall
overall Revenue to range from 61 million
to 67 million they reported a revenue of
91.6 million for the same period that
last year uh let svb fail because
um you know I'm gonna try to be a dick
but then BuzzFeed goes with it so but I
guess what some people in the Super Chat
are saying is that even with FDIC
insurance it's going to take months
before depositors can start getting
access to their funding so that means
even uh one of the craziest stories I
saw because we someone mentioned this uh
last week
Etsy sellers didn't get paid now my
understanding is if you're a seller on
Etsy you like I make a you know a doily
or something and then someone buys it
and they use this Marketplace and then I
send it out but the fact is the people
bought a product Etsy held the money and
the Etsy sellers didn't get paid that's
crazy that's what happens and then what
may happen is even with the the they're
doing the national Deposit Bank from the
FDIC for these companies buzzfeed's
funds might be jammed up and their
employees might not get paid this this
is is going literally to have a ripple
effect now I also want to address this
real this thing real quick too
BuzzFeed saying that their uh their
revenues are dropping due to a tough
advertising Market I can confirm that is
a fact because I've talked about it here
so take this into consideration with the
with the banking industry getting hit
this bad I can also tell you like our
revenue is down not to the point where
I'm crying about it or anything because
we do well enough but that's why I'm
like hey everybody become a member so
that we can continue paying our staff
and continue funding these projects and
everything like that uh because the the
market seems like it's headed towards a
very very serious downturn it's
interesting because buzzfeed's reporting
their ad revenue is down is projected to
be 61 to 67 million down from 91. that's
basically what I was saying like 40 30
30 to 40 drop off
but that right now should be increasing
not decreasing which suggests this year
is going to get really really bad for
media and when media gets hit it's
because the base of the economy the
Grassroots already got hit so what this
is we're effectively a canary in a coal
mine when small mom and pop shops Stop
their 100 budget per month for their
little grocery store or Diner and then
we it all like let's say this a hundred
thousand small businesses across the
country just hypothetically
that are buying a small amount of
advertising it all trickles up into a
handful of small media personalities who
then all yell our Revenue dropped
dramatically basically telling you that
at the individual granular level
revenues are dropping and spending is
dropping which means the next step is
going to be serious economic downturn
with the banks collapsing with the with
BuzzFeed even complaining about it not
that I care if BuzzFeed collapses to be
completely honest it would suck if
people lost their jobs but I don't know
if these are Jobs worth saving that
being said it will have a contagious
ripple effect so the question is
how do you feel about the current state
of things because I got to be honest I
have absolutely I mean maybe maybe I
don't want to pull Bill Maher here but I
personally have no problem myself with
having to go and chop wood and then
forage for food literally we ate chives
fresh off the ground we go out in the
backyard we grab chives out of the
ground and eat them they're delicious we
have chickens I'd have absolutely no
problem going to a place like fortitude
Ranch rolling up my sleeves and taking
care of animals that being said I don't
know if you all do and that and then
people have kids and people have medical
conditions people with diabetes
especially need access to these things
if you like the level of comfort we have
you probably want the government to bail
out all these all these people
everyone that just like you said
everyone that enjoys a a modern
lifestyle at the end of the day you do
want the banks to be bailed out as much
as everyone's going to say they don't
you have to be prepared for
early 20th century lifestyle
if the banks fail I mean fair enough I
mean but it's like if you don't know how
to do things and you don't have a place
to go and you don't have some savings
and some food and some stuff handled
things are going to be really horrible
for you like I mean the estimates that
you hear after the first year it's
something like 10 if if the US like the
dollar collapsed something like 10
percent of the population will make it
or something ridiculously small it's not
it it's not something that anyone should
be hoping let me read this I want to
read this real quick Olivia Claire says
I'm an Etsy seller I should be getting
paid today for last week's sales it said
it won't transfer until tomorrow I rely
on Etsy as my main income at the moment
really scary time as a seller and
sellers shouldn't have their money being
withheld by I mean you're the person
selling yeah but SVG bees money's jammed
up so let's see if they move in quick
enough and if they don't the crazy thing
is if the individual can't get their
money let's say it takes three months
that means they're not buying
cheeseburgers that means local Mom and
Pop Pop Shop Diner they're not selling
cheeseburgers they ain't buying ads
they're not paying their employees their
employees ain't buying cheese burgers
and it Cycles through and ripples
through yeah but you just can't have
this continue you can't keep bailing out
firms and they make bad investments in
derivatives and spend billions and waste
it and then we bail them out and now SVP
has made bad Tech Investments they've
lost money now we're building you can't
do that forever ultimately people have
to pay for that and the debt keeps going
up inflation's going up and you reach a
point where you can't do it and you just
encourage more of this bad investment
when you bail people out it's called the
moral hazard problem it's exactly what
we're doing when we keep bailing out and
again we're not bailing out you know
small in count people they will be
protected they will be repaid we're
bailing out big tech companies with SVP
just like we build up big Wall Street
firms it's worse than that it's bailing
out wokeness specifically
here's my here's my belief if you take a
look at at Silicon Valley Bank's mission
statement stuff boy did they invest a
lot in diversity Equity occlusion and
access they call it
d-e-i-a they put an extra a at the end
of there and uh and the apparently their
risk Chief risk officer was like laid
off and they didn't refill the position
but they did hire an lgbtq advocate for
seminars and so everyone's like what was
your priority why would that be a
surprise to anybody that a Silicon
Valley Bank prioritized their religion
over the function of their business this
is it's what they do right so here's
what I think I'm willing to bet that svb
started investing in companies based on
wokeness and not Merit so they would go
to a company and be like okay so you're
a tech company what do you do we have an
app what does your app do uh it's a it's
a texting app how will it make money we
have a really diverse team of people who
work here really how much money do you
need uh five
50 million 50 million and you said you
preach diversity that's right great
here's the money our app is so diverse
it lets black people find black
businesses it's the most racist app on
the planet no it's for white people that
can find white owned business like what
they do it's not diverse
segregative and racist like when they
made black panther they're like this
movie's very diverse and it's like the
cast was 95 black that's not diverse
diversity will focus exclusively on One
race of people but what the hell who who
in the audience would disagree with me
one if you disagree 20 if you agree that
svb was likely investing in companies
based on diversity and not based on the
function of their business they were
pretty open about it I haven't been able
to look at the books but they said as
such on their website yeah they did an a
rating with es aesg score my I'm gonna
tell you this I don't want to give
anybody advice but I
I'm I'm thinking about investing my my
money in stocks from companies that have
the lowest possible ESG score oh yeah
and getting all of my money out of
anything with a high ESG score you sound
like Vivek Rama Swami is that what he
said I don't know if he said those
exactly that's what he's all about
investing your money in non-esg right
now well it's it's I think it's I think
that sounds right if a company is is
focusing their efforts on environmental
social governance that is not a
functioning business everything that's
for if you're focusing on social issues
and right now essentially what's good
what happens is ESG is social issues
being shoved into into businesses and
bureaucracies and stuff like that you
see the social issues in in uh
in schools and stuff and that's part of
why test scores are so are going go down
every year you spend more money every
year and test scores keep going down
every year it it's essentially
supplanting the purpose for every single
thing that it touches so if it's schools
it it's it it corrupts them and they and
you and it stops you stop churning out
kids that know anything there's a
There's a comic from Stone toss I know
the left really hates Stone toss but
it's an advertising agency and then the
the advertising guys Market is is he's
got a burger restaurant clients and he's
like here's our proposed ad campaign and
it's a white person and a black person
making out and then the guy's like how
is this going to sell cheeseburgers and
the guy goes cheeseburgers but that
that's a really good example of what
this is the same reason why FTX failed
the uh the crypto thing
yeah obsessively ESG Sam bankman freed
would talk about it I think it was more
to it than that man yeah he's a big into
investing in climate change there's
video of him being like we're gonna fix
the world with impact investment use
different words but that's the that was
the purpose no bitcoin's doing really
well spend your money on what there is
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time